the jurogan experience what are you
telling me about acid
tell me it's right into it yes because
it was very and i stopped you because it
was too good it was like it was very
interesting
well you were saying that you did it
once
and you you were in a bathtub and it was
interesting but then you did it
where were you the second time you did
so the first time i did it i was with
uh three other people and we like you
know
it was celebrating someone's birthday
and all my friends are like
pretty spiritual in that way like
meditative and annoying
you know no it's good stuff i love it i
think i'm kidding i know it can be
annoying i agree that [ __ ] can be really
wrong people 100
when it's inauthentic it's super nice oh
yeah yeah no i i think there's
it's like any other area of [ __ ] you
pick up on it you're like
no i had two different yoga teachers
that did the same thing and with one of
them it was amazing and the other one it
was so annoying
yeah well the guy would like chant in
class and he would sing
and i'd be like let get me away from
this [ __ ] he was just a [ __ ]
artist it was like a fake spiritual guy
but then another guy who did it
his classes were all donation based you
didn't have to pay to
come and you would see ladies pull up in
mercedes and not pay i'd be like you
dirty
they just wouldn't pay was that the good
one or the bad the good one yeah the
good ones
he did the exact same thing but you can
tell there was no pretense yeah
so i'm sorry no i'm i'm with you though
i feel the same way
i have spiritual friends and it was more
of like we i laughed for like eight
hours it was just like
laugh therapy and just around like
wonderful people just good energetic
and i i was so i was high for like two
days
but i found myself wanting to like go in
and i kept
going into his bathtub and like he had
like this
glass door so when you shut it the sound
was
really and that's what i wanted
and but i didn't really get to go there
because everyone's like come back let's
all like hang out
you know and so uh last week
i went with my best girlfriend to
celebrate
her mother's birthday and her mom passed
away five years ago
and we went out to joshua tree it was
beautiful
i mean first and foremost the the thing
that
i admire most about the process is like
setting an intention when you want to
heal from it you know like you can party
like i did the week before
you're just like hanging out but i
wanted to go somewhere
else and we did and
you know there was this moment too where
we were sitting just the two of us we
were sitting around a fire
and my friend's been through some crazy
crazy [ __ ] in her life like dark stuff
and there's this like space of sacred
pain
where like she told me things that no
one she doesn't talk about and she's
like
it comes out and vice versa and it was
just this like
that's the place where we put it that's
the place where
we had love for each other and was like
i see you
i respect all your [ __ ] you've been
through and then we went to like the
next phase of it
of the trip and at one point
you know we were laughing too going in
and out of like laughing hysterically
and having like the best time and then
having these like intense spiritual
moments and
and and therapeutic as such like that's
why i love it but at one point
i don't know how to describe it like we
first of all the stars like
were there was like galactic geometry
like you can just see all this crazy
[ __ ] in the sky
and it feels alive and at one point
we went up it was like this cabin and
then you had to walk up the hill for the
bathroom in the kitchen so you're really
in the middle of nowhere and at one
point
like the frequency changed and it went
and the only other time i'd experienced
that was when i smoked dmt like a decade
ago
and it scared me because i was like
there is there is something there is
like
there is an energy that just presented
itself
and and my friend and i experienced it
at the same time
which i don't think is a thing that
happens for people often
i don't know like i've never had like we
were visited
by like it felt like another star system
i
mean it sounds like hocus pocus but i i
don't think it's always pokey it was
amazing that's why i wanted you to talk
about it i think yeah
i think we're uh we have a limited idea
of what's possible
in terms of like what reality is and
when you do
psychedelic drugs you experience this
thing that you can't experience
naturally right you have this these wild
visualizations and you feel like you're
being visited by
entities and things are communicating
with you and some people say well it's
hallucinations your mind is playing
tricks on you and all these things
sometimes it might be that for sure but
also it might be
possible that there's a frequency that
you can tap into with these things
that's not available to you
right and that these things are always
here so like
there's a lot of people that think when
when they're talking about like the ufo
phenomenon there's a lot there's a lot
of people that think these things aren't
just visiting from other star systems
they're visiting from other dimensions
right and that they're there all the
time and they can't come
in and out and they can go and we we
were like oh
we're like trying to grab ghosts like
we're like i just need to bring it home
and show everybody proof
right you're never gonna you're never
gonna have proof it's like it's not
it's not available in this plane but
when you do mushrooms or when you do
acid or when you do dmt
you get these windows into like what's
around you all the time
yeah i think if you pay more attention
to energy in that way too it's like
this is gonna sound super weird but i
it's it is the truth like
my my friend you know her mother was
this like incredibly
like spiritual mystic woman and she
collected uh gemstones from all over the
world and
jewels and one day uh kp
my friend was like she's like suze i
really want you to have some of my
mother's jewelry and it was like
a great honor and i was like well yeah i
would love that and i'm wearing some of
it right now
and um i started having dreams about her
mom
and it felt very like visited
and it wasn't like it was really
beautiful so
like that stuff when you
are taking psychedelics and you have an
intention of like
settling things you know it i believe in
that like the fact that we both
experienced this frequency change at the
same time and i was like are you
are you hearing that and are you seeing
that because it was like
it was like the the whole sky like
it flipped it was like a photo negative
it was so crazy i'm missing out man
i'm not having done lsd dmt none of
those things let's go
i've done mushrooms and i don't know how
you can like hang out and be with people
i always kind of i start laughing a
little bit and then i start to find
myself
like disappear and i'll be like hanging
out with a tree or something
that's awesome but that's great that's
the best part yeah i mean
that's the the best part of mushrooms is
nature right yeah
yeah but there's something you
definitely get from that you know
feeling re-energized and you know kind
of like a reset that's kind of what i
get from that
it's phenomenal for people with ptsd
yeah
people with ptsd a lot of soldiers
experience uh these mushroom
trips and just relaxes them relieves
them of a lot of the pressure
right that they have yeah you know it's
um
but like per your point like it is
important to make sure you're
in good hands with whoever you're doing
it with like and it could be like when
you're good buds but like sometimes like
you know when some
some folks don't quite have a handle on
their darkness you probably don't want
to do
acid for the first time with somebody
like that you know and that's no
disrespect to people
you know that have [ __ ] to deal with
it's just like because
there's no um there's no seat belt you
know like you're just
going yeah that was my first my kind of
first trip was hanging with a bunch of
folks and we hadn't
done it before all of a sudden you know
the guy's house
i was skipping high school i'm like i'm
skipping high school and so we spent the
whole day with like tripping balls right
and then all of a sudden he freaks out
and so i got to go home and i'm
skipping so i'm just kind of standing
out walking around my neighborhood
staring at me
and signing [ __ ] with nowhere to go i
finally go back to my house
tripping balls my mom's there my little
sister's there my grandma's there
no i just went up to my room just curled
into a ball i remember
one time tripping it just only happened
to me once but one time tripping where i
i felt like i could see
the patterns of of existence
that aren't available within the naked
eye like i could see
that there's like some weird like grid
to everything
yes the grid you've seen the grid yeah
i've seen it
yeah it's like the matrix it's so weird
it you kind of like
you feel like you can almost step
through it sometimes you can you can in
meditation too
no it's for real i have seen the grid as
well catch
new episodes of the joe rogan experience
for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience